today we're going to discuss something
called methylene blue now I haven't done
a video on this ever simply because not
a natural remedy it's actually a
synthetic drug but it is sold over the
counter and it's been around for a very
long time and it has some fascinating
properties that I think you need to know
about now it was discovered in
1876 I'm not mistaken and it was the
first fully synthetic drug in medicine
it was used as one of the first
antibiotics it was used as one of the
first antipsychotic drugs in 1891 it was
used for malaria in fact nowadays even
the emergency room doctors have it ready
if someone has either cyanide poisoning
or carbon monoxide poisoning and so it
is a compound that creates some very
interesting effects at lower doses it
can act as an antioxidant I'm talking
about the dose of 0.5 milligrams to four
milligrams per kilogram weight so for
example I weigh 185 pounds okay
that's roughly around 84 kilograms so if
you do the math I would need per day
roughly On The Low End about 42 drops
because it comes in liquid and uh in one
drop you have 0.5 milligrams so if I
were going to take it I would take like
10 drops in some water four times a day
and if you're going to try this remedy I
would definitely make sure you get the
USP pharmaceutical grade at one percent
solution which will give you about 0.5
milligrams per drop so what type of
conditions would methylene blue
potentially help someone with well
septic shock especially if the blood
pressure has dropped significantly
anaphylaxis which is anaphylactic shock
a very severe allergy reaction if
someone had a virus because it has very
potent antiviral properties it's good
for brain fog memory loss it's been
studied to help people with depression
or anti-candida properties as well it
also apparently is really effective in
tissues that demand high amounts of
oxygen which I'm going to explain in a
little bit why like neurodegenerative
conditions like Alzheimer's Parkinson's
it's even good for things like gout
because it can help break down uric acid
and low doses it acts as an antioxidant
as well as an anti-inflammatory so
typically anything that involves
mitochondrial dysfunction and benefit
from methylene blue so what I want to
explain is
um
how it actually works what is it doing
in the body which is actually a this is
very interesting so what it does in the
body it acts as an artificial
electron recycler now let me kind of
explain this
let's Envision you have a battery right
and batteries are filled with these
electrons that are stored right and so
you need these electrons to generate
energy and you also have electrons going
on in your body as well in the
mitochondria in fact your body converts
food into electrons stored in the ATP
molecule for energy and so in our
mitochondras we have a lot of electron
transfer exchange going on methylene
blue apparently has the ability
to remove or add electrons depending on
what part of the body needs them or it
doesn't need them so it seems to help
correct this shuffling round of
electrons which medically has this term
called redox cycling so this is one of
the reasons why this could give someone
with fatigue more energy now since we're
talking about the mitochondria
and this is the heart of your metabolism
in the conversion from food into energy
oxygen is also involved so methylene
blue helps the mitochondria absorb and
transport oxygen it actually improves
the way the body uses oxygen and so you
can imagine all the different problems
that this could potentially help someone
with now there is some contraindications
if someone is taking an SSRI which for
depression for example you wouldn't want
to take this as the potential side
effect of increasing too much serotonin
and of course before taking something
like this check with your doctor just to
make sure there's no contraindications
but I wanted to put this at least on
your radar so you can understand a
little bit more and you can maybe buy a
book and and read up on it but I think
it could potentially help a lot of
people with certain
problems related to this oxygen and
electron transfer issue inside the
mitochondria now since we're on the
topic of this mitochondrial dysfunction
if you haven't seen this video
you might want to check it out